welcome to the acrost this bolivist
podcast as always I'm your host Paul aka
the Pooh Beetle joined by none other
than Greg Alba from real rejects we just
want to get straight into it I think
Blue Beetle was a good movie Greg you've
had a lot of takes on it you know you've
you've been quite positive about it
why has it flopped what's going on ah I
think the DC brand is truly tarnished
man you know we've talked about how the
Marvel Brand seems like that's been
getting a little bit damaged here or
there but then it like rebounds with
this phenomenal Loki season 2 trailer
DC though on the other hand it has just
been feeling like this is progressively
flopping uh over and over again Shazam
for your the gods tanked The Flash
tanked and then on top of that too when
you look at the cinema scores for the DC
EU films I mean Blue Beetle kind of
belongs in that weird camp where it
could be DC EU slash DCU
the cinema score for this is also a B
plus so most of these movies have been B
pluses I would say very few come in at
an a cinema score
and when you think about it the audience
reception to it when they're associated
with the DC brand you know I'm talking
just general audiences as well they
might just not care or have that much
emotional investment in it and this is
kind of where I think why James Gunn is
really dead set on creating a proper
interconnected Universe because an
interconnected Universe this would
really come in handy right about now
because when you look at you know what
happened with like Marvel phase one
through three where they were
introducing a bunch of characters who
most of us didn't really know about or
kind of obscure
a little bit more Niche when you think
about like the Ant-Man Guardians of the
Galaxy characters who are not as main
name Staples such as like Spider-Man or
whatever the reason people still tuned
in is because of the interconnected
Universe because it's the Marvel Brand
so people still have that faith in it
people still went okay we'll still go to
the theaters is this Marvel we'll go
check them out whereas obviously when it
comes to DC that connection that
association with the audience is just
not at not there and the marketing for
this movie didn't do it any favors they
didn't really do it much to really make
it seem special or truly stand out
because you know like a last podcast we
were here I was telling you like I got
no it's actually good man it's actually
fun but you were still here saying ah it
looks kind of generic and predictable
and a little rehash of other things and
while it is sort of that still it still
did a good job at being what it wanted
to be it still did a solid stomach but
the the push for this film didn't know
no favors from from WB it's like they
they lost all their money on marketing
for the flash so there's a variety of
reasons of why I I think this movie
ultimately flopped which I'm sure you
have uh you have some better say than I
Paul because you're very passionate
about this subject
obviously when films you know do badly
there's more than one reason it's never
just the one thing that you can pinpoint
and there's lots of things normally
going on behind the scenes just kind of
going back to the thing you talked about
before when you were talking about how
interconnected Marvel is I completely
agree and when I was thinking about this
interconnected Universe with DC they
don't sort of do it in the same way that
Marvel does now they obviously rushed
into doing a team-up thing but since
then a lot of the movies have just been
focused on Soul characters whereas
something like Civil War it brings all
the Avengers together but it also pushes
black panther as well and you know even
Ant-Man had the Falcon appearing and
these big team films they do sort of
help to push the more obscure characters
so you get used to them and you really
want to see their films whereas DC
haven't really had that thing where
they've kind of brought you know these
had a big Team Up movie with all they're
already established characters and then
push them obviously you know the flash
that worked on Aquaman and you know
those characters were in but since then
they've not really had like you know
Birds of Prey or or something to that
effect where they've had a big team up
thing and it's it's pushed characters
like Blue Beetle and Shazam Shazam
hasn't interacted with any of the other
DC characters other than Wonder Woman at
the end of Shazam too but I feel like
that could have helped and you know just
looking at Blue Beetle's box office so
in case you're unaware and the film so
far has grossed 25.4 million which is a
massive massive underperformer it was
expected to do about 30 million and to
just give you guys a kind of rundown and
for the next part of the video I'm just
gonna go through all of the opening
weekends for every dceu film so you can
kind of get an idea of where it sits
amongst those Now spoiler alert it is
the lowest one but yeah man of steel
opened to 116 million opening weekend
which you know Warner Brothers didn't
like at the time but I think if they got
that now they'd be they'll be over the
moon
um bvs and followed that that did 170
million opening weekend obviously you
know very good
um very impressive but wasn't enough for
Warner Brothers Suicide Squad
133.7 million Wonder Woman 103 million
Justice League or rather Justice League
94 million Aquaman 72 million so you can
start to see that there's a downward
Trend here Shazam 53.5 million Birds of
Prey 34 million Wonder Woman 84 16.7
million I don't feel like we can you
know blame that too much because it was
obviously you know during the pandemic
in winter and it dropped on hbr Max day
day of and that was the same with
Suicide Squad which was 26 million and
Shazam two then got 30.5 million The
Flash came in at 55 and Blue Beetle now
sits with 25.4 so out of them it is the
lowest performer even lower than the
suicide squad which obviously released
on HBO Max day in day
um and it was also you know a sort of
sequel to that that movie that not many
people liked um and it is crazy just
seeing this complete downward spiral I'm
kind of Blown Away by it and I'm I just
don't understand how Warner Brothers
managed to mishandle this so badly like
I feel this is going to be studied in
future business lessons where it's like
you know marvel had didn't have any
characters at all really they had all
their c-listers and they built this up
whereas DC owned absolutely everyone no
there was no rights from stopping them
making any movie that they wanted to and
the only thing that got in the way was
themselves
um and it's crazy thinking about how
badly this has been mishandled because
you know I I genuinely like the movie
and the more I thought about it the more
I liked it I think you know
it does kind of suffer from being almost
it's a copy and paste of lots of other
different movies and there's nothing in
here that really stands out as being
truly original but it's got heart to it
you know the performances are good you
can get on board with the characters I
know they they play they're playing up
the whole representation thing and
saying it's very important for Latinos
which obviously it is but even as a
white guy from England can completely
relate with the movie
um can put myself in the the shoes of
them easy and see things from their
point of view
really enjoyed it um and I think it's
going to be one of those movies that a
lot of people are going to come around
on and and enjoy but like you said you
know it didn't have that push initially
now going forward with the DCU we're
gonna sound like broken records because
we're talking talk about this every week
but seeing this box office what do you
think is the plan going forward will it
change or rather is gun gonna stick to
his guns puns not intended and just be
like no we've gone ahead with the whole
plan that was you know bringing these
characters in first hero of the ECU
I think gun is going to stick to his
guns on this one I think he has to stick
to his guns on this one because
it would just seem Warner Brothers is so
reactionary already like their
reputation has been that way and this
was already
Blue Beetle was done before James Gunn
ever stepped into the fold and so while
he's been working on this transitionary
process with the old DC regimen to what
James Gunn now wants to do he's been
factoring in the story lines as well so
yeah I don't think mobile 2 is gonna
happen but I still think Jaime Reyes
will ultimately carry on and I think
James Gunn is also the kind of person
who would probably be paying attention
to what's going on at the MCU right now
and noticing kind of the audience
reaction to that and as we were talking
about interconnected universes as well
it got me thinking about how well one
thing about it and it's more than just
being interconnected it was also about
having that goal when you're talking
about a team up movie it was about what
was the goal of what they're all
ultimately fighting towards you know
what was the big bad or whatever the
case might be they needed to have some
type of through line that way the
interconnectivity seemed purposeful and
meaningful right that it's not just
about hey it's in the same universe so I
think that's what James Gunn is going to
want to establish pretty early on that
way we can start getting on board not
just something to rush to like another
Justice League or something like that
but if there was that situation with
Blue Beetle if Blue Beetle was lumped
into that category where it was headed
towards a clear direction or some type
of team up or some type of
interconnectivity and then I think more
people would have been on board for the
project itself but right now
yeah I think James Gunn is just gonna
have to
I think he's just gonna have to go with
what he's got planned it's a really
unfortunate situation what's happening
right now because he's got everything is
really relying on Superman and I guess
Creature Commandos but everything is
really relying on Superman Legacy at
this point to see if this will be worth
anyone's time
I'm kind of worried about it I I'm
really concerned about the DC I'm
concerned about superhero movies in
general if I'm being honest like this is
all just kind of uh yeah so I'm in the
opposite Camp I actually think he will
change plans but he won't have to do
much to do it and because if you think
about the way that the guys kind of
ordered his slate around there's nothing
actually announced in it that is Reliant
that much in the dce obviously you have
stuff like Walla Peacemaker season two
but in terms of the projects you know
the big movies that they've announced
there's nothing carrying across these
characters for example he's not
announced a flash sequel he's not
announced
um something like Shazam 3 or Bluebeard
yeah two they're all things like
Superman Legacy Batman the Brave and the
Bold which is obviously going to have a
new Batman even though you know we've
heard those rumors of Wonder Woman 3
being with Gal Gadot the themaskara
project that they've announced that
doesn't really need to be tied to her
and I unfortunately feel that they you
know I've said it time and time again
they just need to hard reboot and and
cut their losses because
I I think that being connected to this
universe it's gonna drag down the new
one because we watch it we'll be there
opening weekend every single time but
when you look at these box office
numbers the audience they're obviously
not there this this is a superhero movie
that used to be the Golden Goose in
Hollywood a license to print money and
the fact that it's not even made its
projected earnings which were very very
low to begin with of 30 million dollars
the fact it's not hit that that has to
be sending warning signs and I don't
know how there's not people in Warner
Brothers right now panicking and going
and can't we just delete that video
where you promised that Blue Beetle is
going to be the first hero of the DCU so
really really quick uh so what you're
saying is that the way he's going to
make a change is what you think he'll do
to make a change is he's going to
completely sever all ties any connection
whatsoever to the former DC regiment
like any so would he can like Peacemaker
or what he can you know Margot Robbie
coming back as Harley Quinn you're
you're thinking that's what he's gonna
do
yeah and that is purely not only from a
creative like point of view but also
from a business point of view because
you know Hollywood people just don't
have this 250 million dollars lying
around to constantly be making superhero
movies that bomb and even when they do
lower budget ones like the Beatles if
they still don't return the money then
investors are gonna panic and I think
it's gonna be a very hard sell so even
business-wise I think they're gonna have
to really pitch this is oh no it's not
connected to that thing that's bombing
it's a brand new universe that we're
taking in a New Direction now even from
a creative point of view I am genuinely
interested in a James Gunn Superman
movie but what I'm not interested in is
James Gunn Superman movie Frankenstein
into being connected to this old thing
that's sort of Canon but not really
because the flash wiped it and I think
in general it's going to damage the
brand if audiences feel like well there
is sort of a loose backstory that I have
to be able to understand and go through
to to get my head around characters like
Harley Quinn or um Peacemaker or someone
like that I think that's gonna really
drag it down and I I have a theory on
what I think happened with Warner
Brothers in DC when James Gunn was hired
now I can imagine they had these four
movies on the Shelf
um James came in and was like look I
wanna I wanna reboot this universe I've
got a vision for it
um but what we're gonna have to do is
basically go with my my thing and he
what I think happened is that he got
brought in by Warner Brothers told you
look you're gonna get full creative
control but you have to promote these
unreleased movies like that part of your
universe and act you have to act
enthusiastic about them and that'll help
mitigate the losses from announcing a
reboot now this is why again I think
nothing from his like is connected to
these movies
um at least what we know anyway the
chapter one slate doesn't really have
anything that you can tie into this and
I think that was done purposely to see
how these movies do and kind of leave it
open for oh if there is a big success
then obviously we want to continue that
and the fact that they haven't I think
spells are that they're not going to go
that direction and and if they do
personally I think it's a bad business
move so they've left the door open for
these follow-up characters but they've
not announced them as part of the
chapter one slate because doing that
will tie them into this old dead
universe and that's not something that
investors are going to be excited about
you know the people running Warner
Brothers who are going to have to fire
people if a movie does badly they're not
going to be excited about that and James
good in general is probably not going to
be excited about his Universe being
attached to this thing that's not doing
very well well like if you were coming
in with a brand new plan you'd want you
know the best stuff for it and I think
coming off something that's not doing
very well it's not going to help out
um and I think that the whole enthusiasm
thing gun kind of did to his own
defament like he came out he was very
positive about these movies said flash
was one of the best comic book films
that he's ever seen he said Blue Beetle
was the first hero of the DCU but there
was also this undercurrent when they
were doing the promotion for these films
that if you want to see these characters
more in the future you have to go and
see them at the movies and I feel that
was spelling out that they could be used
as part of the plan but if they don't do
well then they're not going to be
um and I I think you know I've said it
time and time again hard rebooted please
it just makes the most sense
and it it is kind of a feel for gun
because he is in a weird place where the
DC Brand's been so damaged there's
clearly not the interest there you know
that there's fans who are heavily
invested in the Snyder stuff like I I
was I would happily see another Zack
Snyder DC film and there's fans who hate
all that stuff and want it gone and he's
kind of waded into a civil war with his
vision and I think he's unfortunately
tried to please everyone where he's like
it will be attached to this old Snyder
sort of universe thing but by going in a
new direction and you know it's a theory
um but I doubt that they would have
hired him without the contractual
agreement that you have to push these
unreleased movies
um before we start really moving into
your stuff well yeah they got to make
they got to make the money like they
already threw down all the money you put
it all together so if he's gonna be the
head of it and he's going to make an
announcement to try to be the Savior for
it they got to make their money back on
it some somehow not everything can be a
Batgirl tax write-off yeah and just in
general you know we know how
corporations work
um there's things that happen behind the
scenes where there's
big massive [__] storms going on
um but the way that they're handling
things public facing with the pr is
everything's fine it's all going great
we love it yeah and that's kind of how
guns came across to me and you know
they've never really commented on how
badly these movies have done and they
just seem very positive very
enthusiastic when you know for a fact
behind the scenes you lose a couple of
hundred million dollars on something a
lot there's gonna be a lot of talk and
you know I've worked in places before
like a pub where I got in trouble
because a bottle of wine went missing
once and I had nothing to do with it uh
but the the managers were like we're
gonna inspect everyone's bags and yeah
for them to freak out over that you know
a corporation upscale is going to go
mental I mean it made it sound like I'd
stolen the bottle away in there guys I
hadn't they searched my bag and found
nothing but it was just one of those
things where uh yeah you know you know
what happens in the and stuff goes
missing and for that little money you
know a three pound bottle of wine or
whatever you you scale that up 200
million dollars the corporation they're
gonna go bloody blue mental
um and I just feel in general because
ever this whole thing you know start
afresh and give us some time out even
Aquaman 2 we've still got to sit through
that there's some there's one more [__]
sandwich to swallow and then uh yeah I
think you should start again
this sound honestly everything just kind
of needs to go back to the most simple
Basics and this is easy this is a tall
order to ask but it's also
it's also what they just need to do they
need because it's going to sound like so
so stupid but I'm just gonna say it they
need like consistently great films I
think at least three great consistent
films in a row that reach a great
audience appeal at the same time I know
that sounds incredibly broad incredibly
General but that is pretty much what
James Gunn's Universe needs starting off
with Superman Legacy and I don't I
honestly forgot the the rest of the
release date slate that comes after that
but app from Superman Legacy and
whatever the next two films I believe I
I believe in the rule of three and I
think that after Superman Legacy
whatever two follow those need to have
great audience appeal and they need to
be great films they just have to be
great in order to change the audience's
mindset around what DC films are like
because I know we've been here on this
podcast before and we've talked
extensively about how we love the stand
loans like Joker we love the standalones
like the Batman but those names are are
so big already they they can handle a
standalone you know so as much as we
love the idea of like the DCL swirls as
much as we love the idea of doing a
little bit more of these standalones
what really needs to happen right now is
brand repair when it comes to people
knowing it's the DC name associated with
it I think we could audiences can
separate themselves when it's something
like a joke or when it's something like
the Batman or whatever and I know Blue
Beetle wasn't really relying on
interconnectivity but right now what DC
really needs more than anything else is
just to change its image like the image
repair is the is the number one concern
so it's as simplistic as it sounds yeah
they just need some truly great films
that audiences can connect to it's it's
that simple yeah and just kind of going
back to the the earliest Point again
um so you we talked about how different
heroes are being ushered into certain
movies and introduced there and then
spun off into their own thing
I've just been thinking about it and
that's what James Gunn's actually doing
with Superman Legacy so obviously
getting Green Lantern we're getting
members of the GSA in it and I think you
know if that film performs well and they
can kind of Branch out with that and
make other movies off to the side which
I think is the best way to go
um and you know I think everything's
just uh been a weird mess behind the
scenes with DC to the point that it's
bled through and the drama is very
apparent when you watch these movies or
read reports or you listen to podcasts
where two smarmy guys talk about it
um I actually think that Blue Beetle was
so good that they could have waited
until Superman Legacy released and then
dropped it held off a couple of years
um let the universe build up instead of
sending it out in a weird place where
everything's kind of in flux because
when you think about it it's sort of
being marketed as a standalone movie
where you don't need to go see the other
DC films to enjoy it but it's also kind
of tied to this dying Universe whilst
also being part of this new DCU universe
and I feel like it's in a state of
yeah and exactly and I feel like it's in
a state of flux where it just got
dropped out a really bad time
and because of that it suffered at the
box office uh but I think you need to
worry when you're actually making good
films and they're not making money and
it's doing it consistently and it does
make me wonder and we've talked about
this before at what point to DC just cut
the cord and stop it because you know
looking at the numbers they've had seven
films in a row that have flopped and
underperformed
can how many more films can they go on
connected to this universe before it
finally sinks in and it hits them on the
head like you need to just stop this
universe because it's never making money
you just constantly burning cash and
you're sending these Heroes to die that
could be used in a new thing but now
they're going to be burned because it's
going to be difficult to use Shazam
again
um if you recast them it's going to be
the same with Black Adam or even Blue
Beetle they're gonna have difficulty
because they've sent these Heroes out to
die and basically take the hit whilst
they start this new universe so yeah I
feel like just cut the cord say once
Aquaman 2 is out of the way
you know after the Snyder Cup released
they the Warner Brothers execs put out
an interview saying it was a cul-de-sac
to nowhere just do something like that
say oh we we reflected on the box office
performances
we think Superman Legacy is a great
starting point for a new universe and
going forward this will be the brand new
thing that you don't need to know any of
the other stuff because it's not
connected to that it's a brand new
Superman story and a couple of years
after that you're getting Batman Wonder
Woman but building up something new
James guns at the helm and yeah we're
very confident where it's going and we
think the audience is going to love it
and this is probably going to be a time
where Marvel's sort of
maybe on the back foot a bit because we
can sort of see that coming in at the
moment and I just feel like yeah now to
now's the time to just get Aquaman 2 out
of the way they're not they're not going
to announce anything before that but
what one sets out just say okay it's
over
we're starting it again they need a a
clear break they need a pot like a
positive clarif clarifying
time Gap so that way you need to have
like a breakup period is what I'm saying
because I think sometimes when you're
releasing these so close together and
it's like you can do Aquaman too and
then if they release I don't even know
what the time frame would be for
Superman Legacy for it to properly feel
like okay now now we're in restart
territory
like a year might even be too soon I
feel like a two to three year as as
Panic fraught situation as that might be
I think like a two to three year break
that way you really get some clear
distance
you say five years
yeah wow that's a long time even my
chest kind of tightened at the thought
of that five years five years if it
saves some hundreds of millions of
dollars and get some distance between it
you know it's gonna be worth it in the
long run one of the big debates that's
been going around for say about the last
year and a half is whether superhero
movie fatigue is a thing
and you know I've been thinking about
this over the weekend
and I think yes I I think it is real but
that comes with the caveat that
everything eventually gets to a point of
fatigue once it becomes oversaturated
um and and you can you can the next big
thing after superhero movies this will
have the exact same thing happen to it
as well
um and what Studios basically do is that
they see a genre they can milk and do it
until it's dry and then move on to the
next thing
the the process and the way that things
tend to go and obviously westerns is the
example that always gets brought up but
I guarantee this will happen with the
next big thing like video game
adaptations or whatever is that you know
Hollywood will do that General audiences
will get bored once stuff becomes the
norm and they just keep seeing these
tropes over and over again and then
they'll then move on to the next thing
that becomes popular Hollywood then will
then you know milk that dry and rinse
and repeat now I think in the case of
Western's there there will still be
comic book movies but I doubt we're
going to get the amount that we used to
especially going forward and so I I feel
like you know superhero movie fatigue is
actually a thing I know the the thing is
always like you know it's a good movie
fatigue and bad movie fatigue or
whatever but I think you just can't keep
doing something over and over and over
again and expecting people to still be
enthusiastic about it and to me I think
the studios they just saw this stuff was
printing money and didn't put the effort
in that they should have and it uh
eventually just you know made the the
genre as a whole feel like it was
becoming tired and repetitive
um most people because of that you know
once something gets mundane and and they
get bored of it instead of spending
money on it they're just gonna wait and
and let it go to streaming
and it just feels like we've kind of hit
that point where you're getting all the
sort of characters who you know are
doing them the more repetitive things
like the trailer for Blue Beetle didn't
stand out and really do anything that
felt like it was a reinvention of the
genre and say the way that there's
something like across the spider verse
did which you know did well so I feel
like those kind of movies are are gonna
be they're gonna die out and what we're
gonna see is the more Auto driven
superhero ones or ones that take risks
and show us things that we haven't
really seen before you know that there's
the same quality of a quantity and
that's a saying for a reason Greg and I
feel like we're hitting that point where
there's so much of it that ultimately
everything is gonna suffer because it's
just you know people know what to expect
in the getting bored of it and again
it's not necessarily this is an attack
on superhero movies for example music
genres I mean you can literally look
back through time and see how every
decade had its own music genre that
really encapsulated that that decade and
and people are listening to all the
songs and getting involved in the music
and then the next decade you know people
get a bit bored of that and then
something new and fresh comes along it's
the same with computer games you know
you had side scrollers and then first
person shooters became a big thing and a
Grand Theft Auto clones and whatever
what Hollywood or any kind of industry
will always see something that's popular
that'll become what they think is a
Golden Goose to make as much money as
possible from they'll make so much of
that product and then eventually I'll
hit a point where people just aren't
interested because they've seen it so
many times before and I think you know
this is a process that's going to go on
and on forever and if you look back in
the past it's happened there and
unfortunately you are seeing that this
with superhero movies and yeah obviously
this Blue Beetle box office kind of
speaks to everything as a whole I feel
it's not just because it's a bad movie
because I don't believe it is I think
it's systemic of what's going on in the
industry right now and where the stay of
everything is and where it's going to go
in the future I I think what superhero
genre has I think the word superhero
genre has to kind of
be eliminated a little bit in order for
this in order for superhero films to
thrive I kind of liken it to I don't
really know what the language would be
for this the way how there was there was
a time with anime where it was always
sort of lumped into the same category
every anime property was just oh I don't
watch anime I don't watch anime because
everyone kind of associated all anime
sort of being the same thing but when
you look at anime and the the countless
properties they have there's so many
different distinct genres that you can't
just associate all anime as being the
same and right now superhero films
they're kind of lumped I know that we
can distinguish the differences in
people who are listening to this can
distinguish the differences and whatnot
I think though there is a message that's
kind of conveyed where the superhero
umbrella is all kind of the same thing
and I feel like yeah there's a bit of a
formula that Studios often repeat and
even Blue Beetle is pretty guilty of
that to to in a lot of ways of repeating
other superhero films and I think
superhero movies they kind of have to go
down what what anime to me sort of is
where it's not all the same that there
is a lot of
you don't even have to call it like
reinvention of the wheel like it's just
a I I really don't know what the
language is for it it's that there's so
many different kinds of anime properties
out there that they are a lot of them
are very much distinguishable from each
other that you don't just compare them
only because they're anime properties
you know and I think superhero films
they have to sort of embrace that as
well instead of it just being the same
type of formula do you kind of get what
I'm saying with that I I feel like
that's the direction that category needs
to go
yeah so anime genre
yeah it's a whole genre unto itself but
obviously it has these divisions within
it but there's people who just view it
as this one thing that's
sort of filled with tropes and in the
same way that superhero movies of you'd
like that one obviously we know there's
lots of distinctive ones in completely
different takes on them I guess
superhero films should be uh there
should be a medium not a genre I guess
is what it should be you know yeah that
makes sense
um so yeah what I was going to say there
was Dracula but back in the day in the
70s there were tons and tons of Dracula
movies all the time
um your guy was printing money just
living it up in Transylvania but stuff
like The Voyage of the um demita
um bombed completely bombed and it just
shows how a character can be you know
very popular or a genre like vampire
movies very very popular at one point
and but they get done to death but not
intended and yeah it just kind of hits a
point where the general audience stopped
caring about them and unfortunately you
know that this box office I think it's
it's something that's across the board
if you look at the secret Invasion
figures and yeah it sucks because I mean
I'm a massive comic book fan and I
really thrived on the the popularity
that the genre took on but unfortunately
you know once something it's inevitable
when something gets commercialized and
turned into a commodity by a studio that
don't really understand it like I doubt
David zaslav knows anything about comic
book movies and you know when when fans
on Twitter or something are kicking off
like why don't they just do this with a
character and why don't they just do
this it's because the people in control
don't actually know what you know about
it then they're not David's aslab ain't
reading comics he's got no idea he'll
just like see your name or hear a name
and be like oh well it's a superhero
movie so yeah it makes money push push
him and make that
um so yeah I think that's kind of
where things are at and unfortunately
we've hit a point where it's probably
gonna quieten down for a bit and then I
can imagine that you know
20 to 30 years time maybe the fans who
are the kids now once they're older and
they hit a certain age they'll be the
filmmakers and they'll get in control of
it again and it'll go from there and you
know what I I
I miss graphic novel adaptations I feel
like we don't get enough of those you
know I remember like Road to Perdition A
History of Violence those were those are
like Cinema that is like pure Cinema and
they're based off of graphic novels and
I I don't see a risk I mean I know
they're not as popular and you can't
franchise them anywhere near as much but
I think that is a good direction to sort
of revisit as a possibility because that
was really brought some great film gems
to life I think I mean those are the
only two that are really common is based
on a graphic novel Kick-Ass is graphic
novel
um but yeah I I wish they could do some
graphic novel adaptations again because
and I I think uh I think David Fincher
is adapting one actually this year or
next year I think it's called the killer
or something like that and a lot of the
time they weren't even pushed as like
graphic novels adaptations it was just
like you know if you looked into it you
often find it out but I mean there's
there was so many films back in the day
that I didn't even realize were comic
book movies and then I'd find out that
they were based on graphic novels but it
was sort of like a dirty word back then
and he just didn't push it as that
whereas now if they were released today
it'd be like oh it's based on a comic
book really best-selling comic book of
all time
um so yeah the industry is obviously in
a weird place as you know people who
cover this genre how how are you feeling
about it Greg I'm feeling a little bit
um I guess a little bit dejected
obviously
um I'm not as enthusiastic as
as I once was it's kind of crazy you
know like the the living that you and I
make is so so much of it has been off of
being excited and be and we will be part
like Blue Beetle came out it flopped
yeah but we were both really positive
about the film you know so it's
depending per property Spider-Man across
the spider verse we were both extremely
positive about that you know like it
depends per property and I I get it is
kind of weird it's the it's the genre
that can have me a little bit tired but
still when it comes to whatever the the
individual property is I'll go in with
an open mind and I look forward to it
with enthusiasm before I start watching
it you know but actually you know what I
don't even know if that's the right word
for enthusiasm because I still I do
notice now whenever I go to watch one of
these movies it's not the same level of
anticipation or hype that I once had you
know like no matter what it is Marvel or
DC or sometimes even these the shows now
it's just like
it's another one of the things I'm about
to watch it's another thing where before
there was kind of this you know
alertness I would say that like this
anticipation I'm like on the edge of my
scene I'm focused and that has sort of
withered away and I'm I want to kind of
get back to that like I had more of that
feeling of that of my brain being
activated that way when I watch
something like Oppenheimer but not
not a superhero film and I I miss that
feeling I did kind of have that before
across the spider-verse plane I I will
say when that actually started playing I
did have that but now it now it is just
a very
It Feels So casual now you know and I
missed the I missed the heavy
anticipation uh and and instead of being
a little bit lackadaisical about the
whole experience you know
I think just in general once something
becomes commonplace you obviously don't
get the Buzz for it that used to have
it's the same with relationships
um you know that first year with your
girlfriends gonna be totally different
to how yeah 15 is
um and yeah I think you know I I can
vividly remember waking up for the
finale of One Division and just being
absolutely pumped the next day again
just on a high the whole day working
away you know it was very intense
work-wise but I just loved it the whole
time and then you know we we've I've
probably done your head in the last
couple of days but I've been looking
back at the channel analytics and out of
my top 30 viewed videos from the last
year there were only two Marvel videos
in there and no Star Wars videos which
was I I couldn't believe it because I
kind of feel like I've got the
reputation of being a Marvel and Star
Wars Channel but then seeing that it was
like
oh well I guess maybe I'm not anymore
um and I I have kind of Taken things in
a different direction going with the
classic movie breakdowns and I was
looking at the analytics just before we
started and my last 15 videos in the
most highest viewed videos on my channel
in the last 48 hours I've all been
classic movie breakdowns and it's kind
of hit a point now where I'm actually
enjoying going back to that more and it
it's nice when you're doing this thing
and you actually choose a direction to
go in and it works yeah and that's kind
of where I'm at at the moment where I'm
just kind of I I mean I I am really
enthusiastic about comic book movies
still but I feel like I need to just
take a step back you know take a break
get excited for them again and then go
back into it and which I'm hoping
happens in in the build up to Secret
Wars popping Loki wins me back around
I'm very excited for that
um but there is a Star Wars show that's
coming this week obviously we've got to
see the first two episodes by the time
this video goes out it's just about to
release
um the reviews will now be online we
haven't seen them as of making this but
Greg what are your thoughts on Ahsoka
can we re-record this depending on what
the reviews are
you know if they're well I'm going to
re-record it if the check comes through
if okay I'm still waiting on the check
from Disney they haven't they haven't
actually posted it this week so I'm
getting a bit I'm gonna start slagging
the show off in a second if it doesn't
come through in a second I mean if we
have to do two versions of this I'm I'm
willing to commit the time to it because
you know we gotta be in tune with the
audience and and our money
um yeah uh well I I was messaging you
yesterday
I I saw the first episode and I loved it
you know I I've seen Rebels I've seen
clone wars and I loved it I did I really
did and
I I was curious I did watch it with my
buddy John who has not seen Rebels
and he was able to keep up with it
because it was kind of a bit of that
John Wick effect where there's a lot of
eluding and hinting at history
without sometimes explicitly laying it
out but sometimes not so clearly laying
it out so he wasn't lost on it and I was
especially able to keep up with it and I
love that first episode I love the aura
it's struck I love the tone that it
struck and the visuals or some of the
like to me the visuals are phenomenal
the music is Sensational I think the
music is absolutely incredible
uh this great it's like a great
harrowing blend of classic Star Wars
it's the same guy who did Rebels and uh
there's a lot of like Dread it's a
percolating build to it throughout
the individual performances are all good
and uh yeah I mean like I think
everything on a technical level is
really great and and exceeds Mandalorian
season three for me so far uh like
already
and I thought it was great and then the
second episode started to present to me
some of the worry that I might have for
the show which is
like I love how serious the show is I
love how serious it is at the same time
it it feels a little bit emotionally
detached it feels a little bit too cold
and distant for me at times to the point
where
I I'm
I'm really enjoying the observation
experience I'm having of the of this of
the show
at the same time I'm not as emotionally
pulled into the characters which is kind
of weird because I love the tone and I I
love the mood I like there's there's a
lot of things emotionally outside of the
characters just in The Ether of the
experience that I'm really connected to
but there's just so much
stoism like everyone is very stoic and
it's kind of interesting to see that a
lot of people have been saying it's just
like it's like Rebels season five is a
lot a lot of people have been saying I
wouldn't say that they are carrying the
characters over from there and it's
certainly a continuation of the Rebel
story but it's kind of got that
I didn't even say this in my video but
it kind of you know when you see a
YouTube video that's like we're gonna do
a super I wanna here's my super serious
adult version of rebels that's kind of
what they're doing here where everyone
is so serious and it's so it's so
dramatically heavy that I I actually
feel that the the coldness of It kind of
keeps me at a distance of truly
connecting with the characters you know
and it's not even about to me it's not
even about
um how accurate is the portrayal of what
they were like in the animated it's not
even about that to me like I'm able to
distance from it for myself because I
really liked I like Rebels but there's a
lot of rebels I don't care for there's
so much of rebels I don't care for but
when Rebels is great Rebels is really
great so I'm by no means this Rebels
purest so it's nothing of a comparison
for me but the show itself you know like
like Ahsoka Tano I I think is so
excellent in that Mandalorian episode
um episode four of season two and her
presence that Grace that she has
is it five oh yeah messed it up I think
so yeah [__] look at you there go a
little cocky little smirk on your five
you dumbass
um episode five yeah I thought that was
a great like backdoor pilot for her but
at the end of the day like even though
she led the episode she's still a
supporting character in that show in in
that episode and here in the lead it's
like well
she's not she's kind of just so she she
is like super stoic you know and and so
it's not exactly the most compelling
lead and a lot of people I saw in the
early reactions are sightings Sabine
wren
and I I guess my I haven't really made
up my mind yet on like I love the first
episode the second episode presented
this worry for me of like will I will I
truly be emotionally invested by the
time we get to the end Journey but I
will say
the stuff they are setting up
it without spoiling stuff
what excites me about what they're
setting up is stakes in a situation that
is not just like
oh we're building to the creation of the
first order like it doesn't even seem
like it's concerned with that you know
they're building to something very
different that I think can be unique and
exciting for the Star Wars universe
so
yeah yeah that's that's kind of my one
my one main qualm with it is I'm just
having a hard time truly connecting with
the emotional centerpiece of the of the
actual character storytelling yeah so I
actually
um I agree with a lot of what you've
said I I would push it a bit further and
say that I was I was quite disappointed
in it to be honest um and it might be
because I was so close to Rebels so I
actually I've been doing big Rebels
re-watch and I actually finished episode
four
the second the screen like sorry I
actually finished the finale of season
four the second that the screeners came
in so I literally finished Rebels and
then started watching Ahsoka but I
didn't mean to it was it was just the
timing of it it was literally just I I'd
been working through this for months and
months and then as if fate should have
it you know sometimes I get comments in
my videos like I finished watching 2001
randomly out the blue and then you
uploaded a video on it it was like that
and yeah so that came in so I just
thought I'm gonna put it on watch it
and I feel like you know what a lot of
what lucasfilm does is that they'll take
a character who has a very happy ending
and they'll then bring them back and
start them off depressed and in a
complete opposite situation to where we
left them now that's the case with Luke
Skywalker that's the case with Indiana
Jones it's all Han Solo you know it's
also the case with every character in
this show and I I I'm I might be
spoiling it slightly but this was in the
trailer so I don't feel like it's fully
giving things away but obviously if
you've watched the trailer you'll know
there's a shot for shot remake of the
ending of rebels where Sabine touches
Ezra's mural and then turns around to
see a circus standing there now that
happens again
um and it's kind of them being like all
right well we're gonna go find Ezra and
thrawn now but it takes two hours to get
there and I feel like they've
manufactured this drama off screen to
kind of put them in an opposite place
and then have it so they eventually get
to the point that you know it's gonna go
where they're gonna decide to team up
again and then go out and basically
complete the mission that they said they
were going to do at the end of rebels
which I feel like they should have just
hit the ground running and started there
and that would have really done it now
I'm not saying that in general you know
movies where where you you pick up with
a character and they're in a bad place
it is a bad thing to do
um but I feel like it should have been
handled on screen and a lot of time what
lucasfilm does is that again Indiana
Jones Luke Skywalker they do it off
screen and then you just pick pick up
with them and they're all shitty great
example of how to do it right The Dark
Knight Rises to you know Bruce Wayne in
that he he's he he's basically the same
as Indiana Jones and lukeway you meet up
with him and he's crappy and he decides
to get back on the horse but the ending
of The Dark Knight you can completely
yeah you can completely understand how
he got to that point whereas in the case
of lucasfilm they end it with the
character being happy and then on the
next one I'd say oh well in between you
didn't see it but uh or everything went
to hell so I feel like that's that got
repetitive and I was just sitting there
for those two hours thinking when are we
getting to the point that it's gonna be
back where we were we were at the end of
rebels and I completely agree with your
your takes on them feeling stoic and you
know Hera to me feels like a completely
different character and she's not the
happy bubbly person she was in Rebels at
all don't know why you know she's had a
son obviously in the in at the end of
the the series
um she's kind of very distant and not
really that happy it's the same with the
soccer and Sabine
um
I I think it's funny bringing that up
because we weren't even talking about
the subject but one of the things I did
message you yesterday was like I think
the only real Joy after defeating the
Empire is from I don't want to spoil
where but I I had this like one sentence
I said to you because I yeah I have the
same thought as you as like Rebels ends
in like this is take even if you haven't
seen Rebels this is taking place after
the defeat of the Empire you know and
all this stuff like this should be that
everyone is still in like this really
it kind of It kind of make it does make
sense for Sabine if you I think if you
factor in because they haven't they
don't answer it yet in the first two
episodes right but
um the the with like sure her family is
Mandalorian you know she's got a clan
Wren and maybe your breakdown will
answer it so maybe that's factoring into
a lot more of their of our mood other
outside of Ezra looking for Ezra Bridger
but
okay
it is a funny observation yeah I feel
there's good parts too and I think um
the new Jedi characters you know the
dark Jedi whenever they're on screen I
think the show excels
um the yeah well it's weird the way
we're releasing this because it's
obviously you know most of you will
watch this after the show releases
um but we're actually releasing it
beforehand so the people that do see
this before I don't want to spoil it too
much but they really start off the first
episode with these guys and they just
show you like
these they they mean business and they
also end the first episode with them and
you really get the feeling that these
guys are are something else you know
these these shows sometimes have
difficulty having you know villains that
you really get attached to for example
you know moth Gideon we all we all love
them but when you look at how much he
was actually in those shows he popped
about the end of episode eight of season
one wasn't really in that much of Season
Two Season three was a complete mystery
until like the last couple of episodes
whereas these are villains from the
start and you can instantly see like
yeah you know these guys are people like
they're they're I think they're going to
be the talk of
um the series and unfortunately you know
Rey passed away before he got to see
this which
um it does add like a tower note to the
series because you're watching her
thinking he's completely killed it and
unfortunately he's never gonna receive
the love that he would have if he'd seen
this released to the public so you know
it's got that side to it but we are kind
of dogging on it a bit it is early days
but I don't feel like it's the home run
that's Gonna Save Star Wars at least of
these first two episodes and at the end
of it I was I could completely see why
they released two at once I just felt
like
yeah it's it's fine but it's not it's
not a home run yet
I I I think I'm definitely more I
definitely more positive than than you
are because yeah there's just so much
about the
the the visual language and again the or
these the atmosphere of the show that I
I really do love I really do love it um
and yeah that's a great point about
they they I think they reveal his name
balen uh he's he excellent presence they
have so good their presence striking
like every time they're on screen and
this I think this show is truly elevated
by its amazing score I I could I I don't
feel like you really talked about it and
I I really think like there's such a
variety to the score that I think truly
stands out and uh they show uh who Yang
and the trailers and uh I think he's
good too
um yeah there's there's a lot of cool
the action's okay the action hasn't been
like the most impressive yet but I'm
waiting to say it it's like adapting
Ahsoka into I I liked her action more in
episode five of season two more than uh
I've liked the action that we've seen so
far in the Ahsoka series of her uh
because of the way that was captured
where she was like a mysterious Samurai
warrior that everyone was afraid of you
know like that that was really yeah and
this show does carry it just continue to
carry on those
Samurai Western uh tones that I like I
like a lot yeah there's a lot of just
aesthetic things that I I personally are
very subjective towards my liking that
that do bring a big smile to my face so
yeah I'm just saying all this in case my
check does actually clear so you know
I'm just making making sure it's making
sure yeah so yeah I think you know
we're not completely down on it as down
as we might sound but
I mean it's always difficult being
critics and seeing everyone sharing
something with praise and you know that
you're trying to be the one who's like
coming out and being like oh well you
know am I because you do have doubts
within yourself and think am I in the
wrong when there's so many people who
like it but just being completely honest
um
and maybe I was too close to Rebels off
the back of it but totally I just don't
feel like it was like a charismatic
grabbed me made me feel fun again about
Star Wars bear in mind I've also just
done a big breakdown of A New Hope lots
of fun excitement in that and I don't
feel like that tone carried across to
this it might be good you know it I
would still say it's solid I just don't
think it's like I said I don't think
it's a home run and but obviously you
know you guys are free
are you saying it is I'm enjoying it
more than I mean Grant it's only two
episodes
but so far the appeal of of these two
I'm liking more I'm like oh I could see
my I'm like I'm liking it more than
Mando season three
um it was first too
yeah I mean I remember like the second
episode of Mando season three but that
first episode of Amanda season three I
was like something's off and I remember
really something's really awful this
season I don't know what it is I know I
remember like that was the thing we
disagreed on was like you liked that
first episode and I was like I don't
know about this one yeah
um but yeah no I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm
hopeful I I am hopeful but yeah I think
people should prepare themselves for
it's like I know it's so easy to hear
what we're saying and go oh what you
thought Mando season three or something
was too Goofy and now you're saying what
this is too serious like no it's not
that's not what we're saying they're
you're overs people might well might
oversimplify our opinion here
um it it's really just about the
emotional connection to the the way the
the characters are written I think
that's what it really I think when we
boil that what we're both saying I think
a lot of it really comes down to that
it's really not the pl there's nothing
really wrong with the plot like the plot
is good like every and the Mystery is
good like everything's good all around
it's really just the it's it's really ju
and it's not even like
I don't even necessarily say the
characters are weak there there is a
lack of chemistry amongst Ensemble
though that yeah but with the with Ray
and and um
and uh the uh the the girl like really
watch my words here uh Ray and her uh
like there's there even though like
there's a lot of quietness between them
and it's mainly just visuals and Body
Language between them like I feel the
chemistry between them uh I do think
though like yeah for it being an
ensemble show you do need that chemistry
and and I think especially if you're as
much as a much of a Rebels
lover I think I could see it going
either way I could see people being so
excited just to see the fact that their
Rebels characters are being brought to
the big screen or brought to live action
I could see being that or I could see it
being exactly what you're saying you
know like this is nothing like how I
remember them being because their
personalities
like the performances are good like
individually but yeah they don't really
reflect the animated portrayals to me
even for you as well like they don't
really reflect what what we probably
grew to know about I think Zeb in uh in
in that man in the Mando episode was a
little more accurate but then but then
they also got a lot to reprise it so
yeah I mean we'll see obviously we're
gonna cover the show week to week we've
kind of flipped and reversed roles
because it used to be me getting up
after a full night's sleep again to
cover this stuff and now they've
announced that the times are changing
um which is you know it's it's bad for
me I'm gonna be honest that was like the
one advantage we had but we're not I'm
not getting up early for it yeah I
decided I'm not getting a billy for this
show I just thought I'll just get up and
do whatever because then I'm not having
to convince my editors every week to be
like oh you guys should really you sure
you don't want to get up at 3am to work
on a video
um so yeah it's it's weak we're just
gonna see how it goes
um and yeah that's kind of kind of where
stuff's at at the moment now we've hit
the hour mark Greg is there anything
that I feel like we've done an alright
job of talking about stuff speaking on a
circle is very difficult because
obviously we don't want to do spoilers
so we can't pinpoint certain points that
we had problems with but yeah you guys
let us know and now on to our final
story which is if you've been paying
attention to all the legal stuff in
Hollywood you might have noticed that
there's lots of lawsuits going around
and yeah tsg and a couple of other
companies are suing Studios the the Big
Talk of the Town at the moment is tsg
versus Disney who are taking them to
court of apparently doing some Creative
Accounting and not paying them any money
that they deserved so what happened was
from what I learned was tsg basically
invested in a lot of different Fox
franchises and films now if you don't
know who tsjr you'll know their logo
it's there's basically a guy with a bow
and arrow lets it go it flies through
some ax heads and then stops at the end
so they put lots of money into films and
they were promised certain returns if
the the budgets got to a certain point
and this was all in this 20th Century
Fox but Disney Then bought them and
suddenly you know the money it went a
bit it didn't really materialize now
obviously with the strikes going on a
lot of companies are kind of looking in
their books and seeing where where can
we actually get some money from because
it's going to be quite a hard year
coming up where because so many things
have been delayed and what they did was
they brought in some Auditors to look
over these 100 films to make sure that
everything had been paid out fairly and
they were getting the money that they'd
were promised
um the Auditors found that in all three
so the Auditors basically took three
films as examples and looked into that
now if the if there hadn't been any
discrepancies in any of those three
films it would have been absolutely fine
if there'd been one they might have
thought maybe it's a bit off without we
could look a bit deeper but we might not
you know two start to become a problem
and three which is what they found
problems in all three films that they
looked into they'd been underpaid on so
it started off a lawsuit where tsg are
basically
suing Disney to to get back the money
that they see as being withheld from the
company and paid from one section into
the next without going into them now
those accusations flying around or lots
of bad stuff for example Disney
obviously owned lots of different
subsidiaries for example FX is something
they own they've got lots of different
companies under their names and what
aspects of the lawsuit are accusing them
of is things like you will build a
subsidiary who will then invoice you a
certain amount of money and you'll pay
them but the amount that they're
invoicing is way more than it should
cost and this is simply for you to pass
Ram money from one part of the company
to another saying that you've paid for
certain things from that company when
really you're having and you just move
the money around so that you don't have
to pay tsg back for their bonuses there
was also something to do with
um HBO Max I believe and what originally
happened was Avatar the way of water was
the one
yeah so so there was part of a deal
where
um uh when they were with 20th Century
Fox they made a deal I think with Warner
Brothers that their films would debut on
HBO Max and but obviously Disney Then
bought them but the deal was still in
place so this is why for example if you
go on HBO Max you can watch Avatar the
way of water but if you go to Disney
plus you can watch it as well they're
not exclusive to platforms and they were
meant to get some money from that as
well I believe so if if say they have a
licensing deal with HBO Max you know
they're the first point after the
physical sale ends when it goes to
streaming so normally when a film
releases you have the theatrical release
then go to digital then physical media
then streaming that last point is
obviously they get paid a deal for
licensing that but with it being on both
platforms that deal for license sorry
the cameras will now Focus that deal for
licensing has now gone and yeah tsg have
lost our money for that as well so lots
of things going on hopefully I hit all
those points Greg obviously have you
noticed another one I've been going
through it yeah I've been trying to like
keep up with I think you actually
summarized that really well because I
listened to a couple of videos on it
trying to understand it
um this morning because I was like oh
this is kind of a complicated mess but
yeah no no you pretty much at every fact
yeah through the audit what they found
was that tsg was owed over 40 million
dollars for just the three movies that
they audited but in total they believe
they're actually owed hundreds of
millions of dollars in total so Disney
has been doing a lot of their tricky
Hollywood accounting
um you know in a way that to use trick
accounting to show like less profit and
so they don't have to pay out as much uh
to others who were promised to share and
a lot of this is also echoing the type
of business deals that you know uh
Scarlett Johansson have fought for when
it came to Black Widow as well where she
was saying that because it did the day
and day release and that her contract
was only with getting some profit off of
the theatrical release that she lost out
on so much money due to that fact and
none of that was part of the
negotiations and whatnot and this is
actually the same lawyer that I just
learned this morning that this is the
same lawyer who's working on this case
for tsg is the same one who worked on
the Scarlett Johansson case and if I'm
not mistaken that ended up ruling in her
favor as well so this is like what this
guy specializes in
I think there was a settlement reached
with that because it was very very quick
they didn't go to court or anything it
was a case of you know we got a report
saying that Scargill was suing them and
then it was like three or four days
later that she announced that they were
both working together and do having a
great time and I think that'll probably
happen in the case of tsg obviously you
know the the figure you brought before
they're investing billions into films
and movie studios especially Disney at
the moment who haven't exactly had a
good year a lot of their films have
loved recently though Elemental is
actually done really well so we need to
take that back
um but yeah a lot of their films have
flopped so they don't really I wouldn't
ever want to see why they would want to
annoy an investor who's handing out
billions of dollars because
the the amount they'll have to pay out
apparently it's in like the tens of
millions or something might be upward
you know obviously there's 100 films
there so it's probably a lot more but
I I believe they'd want to keep them on
their sweet side because I mean this
company could just take them to court
and probably rinse them for a lot of
money otherwise so I can imagine things
are going to settle outside of it it'll
probably get you know passed off as I
was a victim of the fox Disney deal we
just we're sorry guys we didn't realize
and yeah it's kind of a bit all over the
place
see at tsg Disney getting sued bad times
bad times for though that Mickey Mouse
and their time with the strikes it is
interesting to see that this is like
because you know we have like the
writers who are fighting for
um fairness pay we have the actors who
are fighting for fairness pay and now
you have a co-finance here like for sure
billions of dollars uh fighting for
their fairness pay as well and I I can
see this having long-term repercussions
because you know like many of these
Studios they have co-finance years and
Disney will rely on that too and this
can is totally
impacts the level of trust that someone
would have to work with and Dizzy's
already having a hard enough time with
their Optics and and their the the way
they everything about Disney right now
is in such flux with the the way
audiences and business people are
responding to them and This only affects
it even more so and it seems likely like
all these accusations they
I I when just hearing it it sounds like
tsg is probably right and probably very
accurate about what's going down and
Disney withholding money like this in
such a clever accounting way it's it's
gonna make me it's making me wonder
wasn't there a whistleblower such I
believe there was like a whistle it's
coming to mind right now there was like
a whistleblower situation not long ago
where someone found some accounting
stuff and that got settled too
um it didn't record anything but yeah
like they found someone at the company
found some [__] and was like wait a
minute something's wrong with the
accounting here and I feel like this
will just lead to more more people
coming out more people saying like uh
things about Disney's handling and with
their legal issues and unfair practices
and whatnot
this can be bad you could say Greg
you could say Greg they were destroyed
by greed remember when we did the
thumbnail and yeah just that greed's
catching up with them on all sides not
paying the right errors not paying the
actors not paying the investors
Sodom yeah they need to go kick up the
ass and if this is what it costs then
good they need to stop ripping people
off especially the creative people and
you know these execs that are just
screwing people over
taking their money not paying them
fairly doing Creative Accounting so they
don't have to pay them out good these
are bloody criminals White Collar ones
but you shouldn't be stealing money off
of companies like that especially if
they're giving the Goodwill to give you
billions of dollars to make movies you
know what I mean after tsg warned they
would sue Disney tried to use a loophole
to say they could buy back rights to the
movies and ignore tsg's legal claims oh
that's so [__] up
that is absolutely demon
but I'll forgive Disney for everything
they've done bad because they've
announced that they're releasing Loki
One Division and Mandalorian season one
and two on 4K steelbook so you can buy
physical copies of them now and I'm a
big physical collector I've got a big
shelf of literally every single Marvel
movie ever and I went back and bought
steel books for them that's why I steal
books separately and put put them in I
thought they were uh I thought they were
starting to to dial back physical media
I thought there was a they were going
down a direction of like Noah which
would also affect this whole thing with
that tsg is talking about too
um but yeah aren't they planning on not
doing physical media anymore
they were but obviously it's a way to
make money so I've never understood why
they did because idiots like me will
spend hard spend like 45 quid on a
limited edition steelbook for a film
that I've already bought on 4K like five
times already so idiots like me that
they get us in and yeah the I mean they
were selling a one division steel book
the other week without an actual copy of
the disc in it you know what I mean
there's there's more on collectors like
myself who will just buy stuff just to
have it
and yeah um but I I think I've always
thought physical media is a viable
stream of Revenue and I never realized
what I never could understand why they
cut it off I always thought you know
there is it I don't think it costs that
much to print a CD these days especially
on a mass production line and if you've
already got the movies ready you've
already got digital copies of them just
put them out there so what they seem to
be doing is making steel books
um which I obviously collectors items as
well so they can charge you a bit more
and yeah hopefully you know they realize
that there's money in this stuff and
they start doing that I think probably
the next step is something that we
always physical media collectors have
been crying out for a while which is
IMAX versions of the films obviously you
can get them on Disney plus but they've
always kind of pay gated it behind that
and I think that'll be the next step
where they release them on 4K and I'll
have to buy all the infinity Saga and 4K
again which I've done twice already now
because I bought them all in 4k and then
they announced the IMAX version so I
sold them and then I realized I actually
like the physical media versions better
so I bought them and uh yeah they keep
swinging me out of money but I keep
handing it over Greg maybe they should
take the money and pay tsg maybe this is
one big scam to finally pay tsg off
probably Man Poor tsg
they're billions of dollars
they have some big movies man this is
kind of crazy this is nuts I'm gonna
miss that logo
sad times but uh I'm sure they'll be
fine I'm sure though there's no way
they're gonna lose this case or at least
not get a settlement
yeah if they had actual Auditors come in
and be like this I mean that could step
into being a crime you know if they've
signed contracts and stuff like that uh
but yeah that wraps up the big news
stories for the week we've done some
reactions we've done some news for you
guys you've had you've added all that
this podcast and uh we appreciate your
support as always you can hit the Thumbs
Up Button if you've enjoyed the episode
you can also subscribe to the channel we
release these sometimes on a Monday but
we're testing release dates but uh no
later than a Tuesday at the moment and
yeah thanks thanks for rocking with us
guys if you want to listen to us on the
go or on Spotify Amazon podcast Apple
podcast as well Greg is there any final
words that you have final five words no
I appreciate you all bearing with me on
this very off day and uh is the day
after the hurricane Hillary
and uh internet's the internet didn't go
out once I'm happy about that man I'm
happy about that that's good you have no
idea what it was like dealing with like
if people were treating it like it was
the the end of the world I went to the
store on Saturday and everything was
just like bought out everything everyone
thought it was going to be the most
nightmarish situation
everything that I am recording this
through is all plugged into a generator
right now and when I was filming Ahsoka
I had a earthquake it happened while I
was filmed it was a hurricane and an
earthquake at the same time so it's nice
to just kind of have a normal Monday
right now so thank you for you guys
being here to help me have a normal
Monday really appreciate it
it's Tuesday when this goes out and we
might all be dead so thanks for at least
having this one day with us guys oh
please enjoy yourself I hope we've hyped
you up for what's coming down the line
and uh yeah Disney you need it I hope
you have I hope you've sent that check
out mate because I'll be soon you next
for all the money you owe me for those
positive reviews when I was shilling
so yeah thanks guys and I'll see you
next time any last final words correct
to finalize your words here
no I'm good I'm good man thank you guys
for everything thank you guys for being
here thank you heavy spoiler community